Hey, Shashank, are you there?
Yes, I am here, Jack. I was waiting for you.
Yep, sorry about that. How are you doing?
Right.
I'm doing good. How about you?
Doing excellent.
How's everything going on your end? How's everything?
Going good.
That's great, great to hear that.
Check apart from this, Evan was saying like you were informing about the renewal and everything. So I guess we are still going ahead with the renewal of Evan, correct?
Yes.
Okay, that's a sign because I thought like it can go both ways. Like you might say no, we might not go. So that's why I wanted to confirm. Okay, let me share my screen. Let me know once my screen is visible.
Drew.
Is it visible now? Sure.
One second, I apologize. I'm reading an email.
I'm audible.
No worries.
Yeah, it's visible.
Thanks. So agenda stays the same, highlights, performance analysis, holiday calendar, action items, way forward and recap. So in last month we can see Evan handled 98 calls and so successfully completed 95 of them, escalation rate of 3.1%. We talked about Evan training but...
She had leaves and then sometimes what happened, she got a last minute call because of which the training could not be completed. Overall, her and she had to drop up mid-training, so the trainer removed her from the group.
Totally. He said like we need to give dedicated time, so we'll choose another slot or another training time once we have this in place, once we have more resources available who want to get trained. So I'm working on that. Maybe I'll get out some plan. I'll ping you.
when that needs to be done. And I have also spoken with Evan on this. She said like, okay, from next time I will be better prepared so that I get off queue 5 minutes before the training starts. So that's there.
Yeah.
Okay, and overall operations is stable with minimal performance issues. I do not see any performance issues because overall she handled 98 calls, 95 workloads, 16 working days, average of 5.94. Mode of support was 96.94% DSRS, 1% DSCM and DSTR.
and other. If we see the breakdown, 74% function stop, 38% printing, 16% scan to email, password reset 18%, fax 3%, and another 1%. Overall, we can see like if we see the details and for which we have.
benchmarks like 3% of the escalation, that's really good because we have a target of 10%. So that's under control. Response time is good around 11 minutes, which is exactly way too less. Repair time is 21 minutes. Travel time is 0, so that's good. Should not be there.
And average calls per equipment is 1.02. That means no repeat calls. And the first biggest thing that we can see, the most of the cases that she's getting, like that function stopped working.
Mhm.
But check, how do you see the performance of Evan?
I have no issues. I will be honest with you. My attention has been elsewhere this past month, but I did review the June numbers and she was right in the pack. I don't have any issues.
Okay.
Well, that's great. I totally understand. There can be some things which can take your attention, but no worries. You validated the number, so that's great. Moving on next holiday calendar, next holiday is coming on July 3rd. That would be a holiday in Marco?
Yes.
Okay, great. So we'll continue our work with Eva and we'll ensure like her performance stays consistent and she trains and upskills herself. Any specific thing you would like to share, Jack, which can be a concern or an issue?
Hayre.
Not a concern, but did you talk to Dan Voss about the contract?
I, I, I, my manager will definitely talk to him because my manager takes the renewal and everything. He already has the details. I'll talk to him to get the connect done with Dan was again, even if the contract ends or if the contract is not renewed on time.
Yeah.
What happens, we still continue, so need not worry about in this aspect, like as soon as the contract ends, we'll remove AY if there's no renewal done. So just one thing, we'll continue with the contract and we'll get the renewal done. Okay, and then I guess Dan would reach out to you for your comments. I think you have already supported.
Yes.
Like your comments with him, so no worries, I'll straight away ping my manager to initiate a communication with Dan Wars.
Yeah, the only reason I ask is just for future planning, right? I have not changed my opinions on it. You know, if they are able to renew the contract, I would be in favor of it, right? But that's just not my decision.
Okay, no worries. I'll definitely talk to Vishal to talk to Dan Voss. It's V-O-S-S, correct?
Yes.
Okay, no worries. I'll ask Vishal to talk to him.
Okay.
Okay, no worries. Anything else?
You would like?
No, I don't have anything else right now. I got to make another phone call. I apologize. It's just lots of fires today.
You have been a very busy man.
No worries. Thanks, Shukla. Have a great day.
Okay, I'll see you next month. Thank you.
Thanks, bye.